Peace. Peace. Peace. VIPs. Let me hear from the VIP, man. How y'all feel after after the stomach? Have y'all been able to get a breather in, recognize what happened? How y'all feel about it?
spin. I'mma tell you right now, man. It's one of them ones. It's one of them ones,
you know, guys, but I thought I'd warn everybody.
man.
I say,"Hey, I'm going to do a summit, a two-day joint. It's going to be different from everything that y'all learned so far. I don't care who you learn AI from. You join this one, you gonna find out.
man. And they done f* around and found out.
found out in a real way too though.
Boy,
The way that it's in a real way, bro, is is what gets me.
it's so tangible. You know what I'm saying? In such a tangible fashion.
It's so dandy. That's y'all. That's what's up. Syncere, how you feel about this one?
Think you know me already. How you feel? It was crazy.
It is crazy. But that that is an understatement because craziness is this part of the
Where?
group. However, all of this I need a strategy call because I need to know the first steps.
Okay.
Um because I I understand each one can do one business. However, I have four el arms connected to one business. So, I need that strategy call. But I am so ready. I've been I have been applying these these um systems now. I'm I'm able to put all the puzzle pieces together because you made it like a fifth grade could understand you and Hitsuyo. So, I'm so amazed that I was able to keep up like a full-time job today. And
I'm still excited. Like, I can still go for another couple hours.
That's what I'm saying.
That's how it is.
That s* crazy. That's crazy like that, man. Yeah, for sure. Um, whereas it all starts with the large language model creation with the you start off with the customization large language model.
Exactly where it begin. I think that since you did come into the I think you kind of made it in the middle. I'm not too sure. Um, but it was the customization and personalization of the language model. um up against plugin, up against connectors, up against skills. That's where you start. And then it'll go to the calendar. Then you'll go to, you know, you'll bring all those business functions over to the calendar based
on your interview with your language model. that create the personalization of the language model. What skills, which plugins, which connectors make sense for my business that I interviewed about to Claude? And how can you claude be the best CEO, CTO, CMO for my business? That customization start. You take it through the the Hitsuyo strategy. Get it audited. Get it intelligent up its knowledge. Use the audit. Use the buildup.
Assign those agents. Smarten them up with a notebook. LM or each agent especially each agent manager could be Tai Lopez, Alex Mosy. You know I'm a marketer. I'm a marketer and sales person.
So this type of people I watch Darby Sty when we talk about new and meny those are the brands inside of how we do ads how we do marketing how we do sales. So even today when I taught y'all is because that's the strategy is working at a million dollar marketing point and fools is getting a million dollars a month because they're targeting the person speaking to the person and then creating the path in which they will walk.
And if they don't walk it, they get ads that say that you need to walk it. It's it's such a um astrological. It really is. Hey, look, it came from some white voice, but it's so astrological is what I'm saying, y'all. You know, when we're spiritual, we say,"Hey, you know, I'm guided by the stars." Even if you're not going to do, you know, because I don't even do the the traditional dillydally of astrology. I'm talking top
threes, top 12, nodes, angles, sun, the moon rising. So, if I understand the numbers and the math like that, they're playing marketing at numbers and map that they're creating and having their person go through a marketing journey and putting them in email content and ad loops that they actually can't get out of.
And it's not that, oh, I can't get out of here. I can't avoid Jeremy Hayes. I can't avoid Spin City. You wouldn't want to after the information that we've given you in ads. So that whole infrastructure of learning from them using the notebook uh notebook um sorry y'all YouTube to notebook LM whole strategy you'll learn so much with the AI agent you're about to create and then that's why I'm saying you go for one high ticket
sale you then go and hire that person as the mentor and a lot of them are not even that expensive a lot of them have things for 5,000$10,000 let's try to go for and gold in them. The themm fools want like 40,000 an hour. I mean, if you do pull that bag to you and yours, you know, I think I'll wait. I just in that era. So, you just match up what era you are in business because a lot of us are here's the thing. This is going
to make you money fast. AI, you know, fractional CTO, AI strategy, uh, extraordinaire, AI consultant, or even when you start to do it in your own business.
The reason why I say start, build it with your own business, duplicate with your own business, so you have something to show, the first time you score that dub, the first time you see that 50k check, please don't change your life. Don't, you know, do what's good for marketing. do what's good for advertising. Um, whole next level. Again, Hitsuyo has rock with me pretty much the whole time. My first um 60,000 in a month.
Yes. I bought diamond teeth. Mhm. I did. I did. But again, it was a part of the marketing that I was going to do for Investfest. I was cool. I had gold teeth. I got my little gold teeth and stuff like that. But I knew what rooms I was going to be in. And I know what I wanted the brand to look like. He does a lot of talking, right? He's on this whole new minty, this a minty green, this emerald tablet things. I say I'mma
spare no expense. And I could have got a I could have got I could have got a big heavy diamond chain.
But a chain, anybody can get a chain. It's a nice necklace. It has the It has the bird on there. Anyone can get a chain. a lot of talk, you know, um, hey, the jewelry's fake, the chain fake. I tell y'all, when y'all want to do jewelry teeth, you can't you can't you can't you can't fake teeth. It's hyper custom. Okay? So, I talk a lot. You see my teeth a lot. They better have an emo table. in there. It better be It better
be white diamonds, white teeth. It look like I got emerald braces. That's the Okay, that's the movement. Um, put a watch with it. Black and emerald. Cool. Jewelry. All for marketing. All for marketing. Other than that, I haven't bought any clothes. I have a partnership with Athletics. I don't need to go buy clothes. Um, shop at Burlington Ross. Um, I feed myself well. So, here's the thing that I've been on on the mindset,
y'all, is as an entrepreneur. Be a professional athlete at it.
Be a professional athlete. Treat yourself like a a professional athlete. Get your sleep. Meditate. Affirm, shower. Uh, well, not shower more. I use my tub a lot just to get that meditation. I vibrate the water. Again, I'm a spiritual person. I'm going vibrate that water. I'm going have water based affirmations, dirt, earth affirmations, fire affirmations. I just take it that deep. Cool. If you're not, you're not. What
I'm saying is take very good care of yourself. Stay healthy. Stay in the gym. Go run. Cuz here's the thing. If you can discipline your body, you can discipline a business. If you can discipline a body to when f weights are about to break your ribs and you went through that. See, this is what I learned. This is my connection between business and mixed martial arts. If I'm willing to go through a six week training camp while
losing weight, getting beat up at the highest capacity, even though I'm getting ready for an amateur fight, I'm fighting pros to get the speed, the angles.
I'm getting socked on. I've broken my toe before a fight. I've sprained my wrist real bad. I had tennis elbow before a fight. The thing is, I was willing to go through all the damage and still show up to the fight damage to get something done, win or less. So, if you're willing to get frustrated with Claude, get frustrated with chat the right way though. See, I'm getting frustrated in training cuz I can't beat my n that's
from the UFC. I can't get my coach that has 16 titles in Thailand and Muay Thai. This m*'s quick. But I was willing to stay in those fights and to try something. Did I score a shot on coach body? Or did I get a take down on one of the top wrestlers and I take those micro wins. Now that's me getting frustrated with Claw. Like Claw, that's not what the f* I asked for. So next time you need to do this, there's actually a
moment happening. You're going to cure your frustrations by getting better. Learning systems. Yeah.
What do you think he's going to learn his system in one day? Somebody, you're going to hear the word MCP. You're going to Google it. You're going to AI it. And all a sudden you know exactly how it works, exactly how to invent something new, exactly how to teach somebody, huh? You go through it. Bruce Lee says,"Pain is weakness leaving a body." Um, I think pain is a signal to the God brain that there's a problem with human
body. That's that's how I mean pain is pain, bro. like weakness leaving a body doesn't always well I mean that's how I see it because I' I've heard that and the Marines they march to that but hey if I pop this wrist and it's f screaming in pain I ain't we nobody like it's my nervous system talking to the god mind like something's going on with my right wrist that's and that's coming from being a personal trainer Um, Dr.
Tonee said,"I went to World 3 with my flow coding platform." We don't buy code. We don't buy but business. And even as I'm speaking of coach Tony, I don't I'm 37. I don't buy many businesses.
I flow code because I know code. So when I show code, we can all grow code. Um, yeah. Coin platform. It came out on top a year ago. Cool. Excellent. Excellent. But yo, we get in a flow state here, y'all. When we're handling business, we're doing business. There's a flow state in every sales call. You get in a flow state when you're doing your meta ads. You get into a flow state when you're building your software. You flowing.
You like you reading s* back. You seeing the reasons why things work, don't work. Cuz again, MMA and man, this n can't get me. Bam. Bam. I'm like,"Oh, dick. Forgot I was fighting slowly." And when you get in the flow, you're both strategically and critically thinking at the same time. That's why I appreciate it. And I've always told him, I appreciate people that can think both critically and strategic. Why? Critical thinking.
You can think critically on the chess board, especially playing with your family. You can sit at the chest for 20 minutes thinking critical like they don't hit me there.
Hey, maybe I won't go with that. You can't think critically in a fight. You could man be popping around. Okay, he's working a jab. There has to be a strategy to Oh, he keeps sping the left hand. Well, I'm going to put a high shield in anticipation for the left hand, but I won't fall for the left kick at the same time. Let me test my jab. Let me test my disc leg. Okay. Now, there's a strategy, but it's critical because
he's going to kick me in the head if I don't figure out the strategy fast enough. So that mindset of thinking critically and strategically that kind of leads to flow. It's like,"Oh, okay. I see that jab. Oh, okay. Hit bam. What? Oh, f got bam." So that's how I see things. That's how I've been able to take my my MMA endeavors into business. And that's why I know the strategies by the content. And that's probably why, you
know, a lot of folk that teach AI, they don't teach it like BNC HQ, KTO, because they don't go to the inside of the game.
They'll take it from the service level. Hey, Claude just launched 5.5. You know what they're going to do? They're going to play a mascot role and tell you what Claude got. They'll probably give you a little bit of a strategy. Hey, I'm not hating on everybody. They'll give you a bit of strategy. Things that you didn't know Claude can do. That's better. But a person, hey, you know you can make videos on Hicksfield. Hey,
you know you can clone yourself on Hey Jen, join my two-day summit. Now you're just on Hey Jen, cloning yourself, clone your voice. What can I do with this clone? Oh yeah, man. Well, you should do this and this. Okay, but I've already paid you two grand. What's going on here? When I teach Hen, do y'all know where I teach Hen from? The Hen developer platform. You know why? Cuz you can create clones too by yourself in your
software. I'm going to teach you from the inside of the game. Hen already is putting out ads and telling other people to come use Hen.
And when you go to hen.com, Hen tells you how to use Hen the best. It tells you how to hen better. All the softwares now come with an information platform. Going to need good strategy and good context if you're going to teach somebody at this level. have to think critically and strategic and go in there and get frustrated and master the mindset. So that's just speaking on mindset. Dr. Tonee says if you haven't all thought
of this yet, you should have agents connected to AI laws acts uh addendums so you're always aware of changes when they're made. Yeah. And that's autonomous agent right there. What Dr. Tonee says that's an autonomous agent watching all the laws. And then now when you're selling apps, now when you're building systems, oh yeah, we're super safety first. We have the top cyber security people. We have the top people in IT,
AI engineering, and development. And even in uh even we has some friends that are hackers cuz we always believe that on one side there's an engineer building it up on the other side the in-house hacker trying to tear it down and that's how we give you safe systems and automations and agents.
We go by the laws, we go by the code, we go by the book when it comes to that and make sure you're safe. We also have something in place that protects your intellectual properties from the inside. And we have a we have a great um business consultant on inside, Dr. Tony, that'll show you how to build it up by the paperwork. You give her a digital business, automated business. She'll protect every piece with a sheet of paper
and a lawyer. What do you do? Play the game. You know how to build it up, know how to grow it out, scale it, etc. Uh, do you have a good word here before we go ahead? We just going to do some Q\&A. Uh, answer some questions, see what we can get made next.
I definitely just want to stress systems, systems, systems, systems. And one of the best systems you can have is that governance, right? Understanding how to actually lay down policies for your agents to follow, right? Building up those SOPs, the workflows, understanding the concept of the job to be done.
Your marketing agent has a particular job to be done. If you do not define what that job to be done is, then you cannot accurately monitor and adapt the system to reach the goal.
Exactly.
Right? Just like I said, it's not just about flying the plane to the city. The plane has to land so that way I can get off of it and conduct the business that I need to conduct. Right? just circling in the air is not the job to be done. The job to be done is to deliver the cargo, right? Which in this case would be me as the founder to a particular new stage of my business that I need to like Spin said, I need to get out
there into that environment, take some licks, take some lashes. You see what I'm saying? learn some lessons and ultimately again adapt, evolve, grow, scale, leverage my experience into more revenue, more ideas. You see what I'm saying? So, I definitely want to stress the governance, not only in terms of how you govern your systems internally.
That's internal affairs. We need to see how the big players, the government is laying down certain things. You can learn a lot about where AI is going to go from watching the acts that are getting passed. You can learn a lot from where technology is about to go, from seeing the acts that are being passed. You want to know why Google is dropping this agent to agent uh universal commerce protocol? Because all of the Bitcoin
coin, blockchain, cryptocurrency. They're starting to gain more legitimacy in the government. So now you have a new digital token that your AI system can use. We already saw this during the leaks from Anthropic when um what was that was that um Cosco had leaked that one time and we saw some of the things that they had planned for the future and
Yeah,
tokens and the ability for your agent to buy things.
the middle that
Boom.
middle
So again, when we look at the laws and where things are going, you got to understand these big companies, they're on the inside.
They're lobbying the government all the time. That's a part of their marketing campaign. You will, hey, look, when you really get to the big boy levels of the game, you got to start marketing to real politicians that can really sign some s* into law on your behalf, or in your favor, at least. Everything's for sale. human attention, even laws, n.
data
It's all data.
manage.
So again, we have Dr. Tonee right there in the chat pointing you into the direct places that you need to be looking into to understand again system 4 intelligence where the future of this particular technology is going. So that way you can begin to prepare yourself to benefit and maximize off what the 99% of the population isn't willing to sit down and read. You don't even got to read it. Point your agent at it and say,"Hey,
explain this to me like I'm five and then tell me how to make it work for what I got going on." You could all yo go to YouTube right now.
AI governance 2026. YouTube to Notebook LM. Now you got it. Now you got it. Now you can go in there and ask specifically, what are the AI laws that are going to directly impact the way I use AI in my business? A lot of y'all are just using AI as an internal tool. You're not necessarily selling AI as a part of your business.
Mhm.
You're just using AI to make what you do better, faster, stronger. You see what I'm saying? That's different than AI being the product and the service that you're actually selling. Understanding those differences is going to determine how you govern your business internally. So that way you don't have to worry about what they doing externally because I already got my eyes on that. I see where the next 10 years are going.
I'm prepared for the next 10 years right now. So that's the one thing I just like to start with. The systems are important. The governance is important internally, externally, everything's for sale.
So that the highest level of marketing is lobbying, buying politicians to serve your end. And if we're not willing to take it that far, then are we really talking black excellence, liberation, or any of these concepts that we like to throw around in these circles? That's what I would like to put into the especially if we got Dr. Tonee right here telling us, hey, this is a whole new technology. These laws are still being
built. We still have a way to get inside of it and affect some things. Set up the policies for states and cities that have yet to figure out how they're going to adopt AI into what they're already doing. They want to, they don't know how. So again, this is what I'm saying. When you come in and you know the laws, you understand the laws, and then you can make an offer that's airtight legally. You see what I'm saying? you
eagle legally with it. Now you dealing with government contracts. Now you now you done opened up a whole new section of the market to yourself.
So these are just the things that I just want to impress upon your minds in terms of understanding the systems of governance internally, externally, and how that increases the value of what you're building and what you're doing for the future.
Michelle, Dr. Tonee says in the chat,"Apply for government contracts. There are there's a lot of money there. Go to ai.gov go and submit your business. We have government relations department.
I'mma say something if you don't mind. SP man,
Yeah. Cook
y'all are sending enough questions.
up.
Everybody's hand should be up. Everybody should be asking questions. Even if it's what does that mean? What is that? What are the contracts? How does this work? Like y'all, this is the ample time to be asking questions. about those arenas. It's like, yes, you can go and build your systems. You can promote your your AI consulting business on whatever level to these corporations, but it's a whole sea of money out there right
now in the nonprofit sector and government contract sector.
You can be set with a government contract for the next 20 years. Remember, AI is is not new. However, it's new to us and again, we're still only a part of that 1% that's actually utilizing it. So, there is no research and development at this time. Do you know if you added a research and development department to your AI consulting firm, how much money the government or the state will pay you? Money you don't have to give
back.
No, that's a strategy.
I'm saying here
Yeah.
No, that's a strategy. The R\&D department, that's a strategy.
And that's what And that's what we seeing y'all. Like I told y'all, like I told y'all, people would see it VIP replay. People would see it general admin replay. This was different. This was true AI money mastery. Okay. So, where where is the money when you build a system this good? How can we, you know, saying, me and have done it down here in South, Georgia, working alongside uh the city, working alongside the state,
um Senate, you know, turn politicians into personal brands a little bit, but the automation of the complaints, right?
when these politicians uh people have complaints and grievances in the city, you can bring them internal apps that make that politician so for the people because there's a connective app. I I don't know how y'all feel about politics, but if you if you were connected to the senator because the senator has an AI app that you go in there, you put your grievance in, you say that there's a pothole over here at such and such.
It been been wearing down cars all goddamn season. Ain't nobody's gonna see the city came over here, looked at this s*. It's starting to piss me off. My kids ride their bike and it can it it it'll take your voice. It'll transcribe it and turn it into a TLDDR. Allow your people to get their s* off. It's been frustrating. Or they're happy about this. They kind of want this to happen at the park. You know, it's been good
for my children. The school, you know what I'm saying? Something happened at the school. It's something a little something a little too close.
And you can come to the politician and say,"Well, we can put all your grievances and stuff right here on this app." That'll that'll hit your email in a TL uh TLDDR, which means too long, didn't read. You'll be able to see something, and then instantly delegate it to that person in the city to see if we can get it on schedule. That person's pleased within a week. Yeah. All we had to do was go down there, spend a couple
dollars, pour some concrete, now that place is flat, and we never have to hear that grievance again. Now when vote vote time comes back up, they remember the senator with a goddamn app that fixed the road in a week. You think a politician that's getting money from the state to put in certain things and to hire certain people. Now look what happens when you're a CTO for a politician. And that's just one political play.
little bit different. I need to try to replace the tires right now. If your politician had an application that said,"Okay, well, how long have you been experiencing this pothole?" Look,
man's been over here six months. I don't know why nobody in the city been by here. The police drive by. Everybody just drive by like it ain't there. Okay. Todd senator says,"Ah, they got a pothole down there on Butner. Get um get the city on the phone. Get the city and concrete on the phone. How much can we how bad is that? Can we assess that and and see that?" Now, a busy ass politician can have something in their hand
or have you as a CTO, a CIO, and then and then imagine what you can get paid because again, the state, the city, the call right now is going to pay them to get something done anyway. And you're and they're like,"Oh, well, I'm bringing in I'm bringing in some people that understand AI AI legislation, blah, blah, blah." Uh, Daniel, your hand been up for me. What's good, bro?
Yeah. So, I definitely appreciate the gyms y'all dropping in. I do have a question, but first I'm gonna give Dr. Tonee somes on what she just put in the chat.
And the reason why I'm saying that about the government contracts is number one,
What?
I'm a veteran and government contracts are always usually in abundance, especially right now with the time that we in. Um, but then I'm also going to second that with somebody that I know directly that I want to uh connect Dr. Tonee way and uh you and I are cool with um I have the pleasure of knowing someone I grew with my whole life that actually is in the head of procurement for the government and they write the checks
for contracts and when last conversation they literally said if you know anybody that is looking for a government contract please are way because actively 100% looking for companies that the government can um facilitate with funds to be to carry out suspicions. Um, so just to what Dr. Tonee said please please please please look into that because that's realistically if you if you contract you set you you don't really and
and you know investing and you stick with Cosco you stick with the whole tribe like you will be good you your your play money right um so I didn't want then I had a question for you or Cosco um so I'm looking at this from my lens which is a collectible space right and I'm uh it was a lot of information from what
right?
I've already digested and kind of um what I normally do when I go into a physical location before I do a car show um or convention, I always look at the demographic, look at the cars, look at the people, look at the age of people, um I know being able to record it in voice and then trans I was recording that in voice and then translating that into a document and then taking that written document put into and make that
for the different shows that I do. Um but I am going to ask one that point right was just one just kind of spun up while we was in class. Um, when I go to connect that with the notebook LM say mentors or the the the notebook LM notes, um, how would I about point the optimal output for that specific
Okay, to me, bro, you was hella skipping, but I think you was asking how does the YouTube notebook LM play go for your lane, which is the collectibles.
So specifically physical which I'm not going to do a mental note.
I'm a document of the demographic basically class that's in that space because that will let me know what type of collectors in that space let me know inventory I need to bring which lets me know the type of bankroll I need to have when I spend in that place um once I get into database right using the different AI I feel it's optimal for note taking and then I'm compiling that with the the mentors and the can you hear
I ain't going to lie, bro. Lie, bro. You remember that rock song, Chopzu? Bro,
Yes, that's that's how you hear me right
every other word was gone, bro. I don't know where it is at, bro. We You might have to type this one.
now.
Something happened, bro. I don't know none of the question, bro. Hey,
All right.
did you catch it?
One second. One second.
Like, bro, I couldn't get none of that question,
Oh, no. No, no, no. That s* was bad,
bro.
bro. Uh, type that. Definitely type that one.
You ain't going to type that one out, bro. You can. speaking into a hey whatever was happening
That boy was talking that machine language.
I want you to say it to AI and get it transcribed. I mean that's kind of going to be my piece for for what's happening right there. Type it into type it into AI and get some feedback based on what you learn and what you know and what and that and then we can got to go over it uh with actual intelligence. That s* was crazy.
All right.
Is it okay to speak to what he was saying?
Yeah. Yeah. Dr.
Because that was g that's
Your hand was up so you can get back in
um every state has a
it.
government uh minority business enterprise department. The minority uh business enterprise department is what gets funded by the state and the government. In order for that procurement often to be able to issue out government contracts.
I just did a a five-day intensive going through how to structure your company properly, not just for government contracts, but we had a a procurement officer out of North Carolina listening in and he was like,"Man, can you please come and just put your curriculum in our office cuz they have all this money for minority business for government contracts that nobody comes to get." And even the people that do come and apply,
they have no understanding, no real un structural understanding of how their business has to be established in order to be awarded these government contracts. And they can't tell you how to do it, but if you come thoroughly set up, you'll get awarded like it's nothing. You don't even have to apply for your awards no more. No more. So, it's like we're missing out on on a a lot of legacy, a lot of revenue that affects our
legacies because these contracts can be awarded for years. So, go to your go your uh minority business enterprise office. That's where you start. Get to know the people there in your state.
Ask them questions. Follow their lead. Follow their guide. Government contracts can be your best friend.
There we go.
Can y'all hear me now?
Um, you can go ahead and try it again.
Yes. Uh yeah, I was just saying to Dr. Tonee point for sure with the government contracts. I'mma connect Dr. Tonee with somebody and uh spin and a coup.
Yeah, we Yeah,
Um you heard that part.
we heard that part. It was like It was like What was uh after
Okay. Okay. Yeah. No, it's um I switched off my hotspot to Wi-Fi.
that
um when I get a physical database documented of the demographic in class right and then I'm using notebook LM for the mentors right in a different compilation of mentors that I would I would want to be learning from right I'm trying to think of the most optimal way to combine that data um outside of the target analytics and target audience so other ways to be able to facilitate and manipulate that data to be to use it
specifically more in my field.
And I think that's kind of where I'm running into a blockage mentally,
want to know how to bring that data into your field. I kind of understand cuz I know you got the you got the cards, bro.
right?
fight Maybe the tool might not. Let me see. You feel like the tool and the that strategy fits with what you even
Right. Well,
do.
I know that definitely for sure using a mentor tool that is about to be crazy cuz there's nobody I as of right now I'm like one of the only people that am well versed in multiple different mentors in this space, right? Because I watch a little bit of everybody. Um,
Right.
and what I was saying earlier is that when I go to shows, I physically mentally, well, no, mentally, but now physically after hearing what y'all was talking about in class, I'm going to physically start documenting what I'm watching, right? And what I'm seeing. So when I go to a show, I normally look at what type of cars are they driving, what are the houses looking near the show, the the age demographic to see, you know,
is it elderly people selling their kids collections?
Is it younger? Is it people our age that's selling their collections? Is it kids that's selling their collections? Right? That's these are all physical things that I document or physical things, mental things that I document that I can now physically document, right? And I'm just trying to think of a the most optimal way outside of the target audience and marketing when I do content or when I'm pushing um to buy collections
from individuals to optimally use this information as a merger between the two.
You got some on here. This is kind of like difficult. It's It's like um you saying you got mentors, stuff around you like what skills and abilities would you would you use at a show? I'm not really sure, right?
This seems more like a like a demographic targeting kind of
I'm not really sure, bro.
database. Like you're trying to align the different pieces of um data you're seeing live at these different events to do what though? Like what are you trying to predict?
What are you trying to Yeah.
Yeah. Trying to
What are you trying to get out of it? That's I think that's the part we're missing.
So,
What are you trying to get out of the system,
get
okay.
per se?
So mentally, which you know it it's hard to go back into my memory bank and see every single show and see the demographic at every single show. But normally what I do is a day or two before the show when I'm going to buy inventory for
Okay.
the show, I look into so if I was in Hickory, North Carolina, right, which is a lot of older money. So I'm looking at the demographic in Hickory,
North Carolina. I'm looking at the um how many colleges are in that local area around the show that I go to. I'm looking at how many card shops do they have in that area because that's going to let me know number one my competitors and then number two the percentages that most car shops buy at.
I would have to beat their percentages, right? So, I'm looking at those things physically, mentally. But I'm only taking mental notes up until y'all laid the game and gave the gyms.
Okay.
Now I'm start thinking about it in a different way. like I could be physically documenting this and alongside with using the AI system to be able to make this into an actual uh system. Yeah. Make this into an operating system to where now I can type in this. I think I kind of just answered my own question now,
Yeah,
but uh
I think you got it. I I hear what you're saying,
So once you start to think about what you had needed because that's what it is.
yeah.
though.
It's like okay then what you looking for and it
Yeah. Yeah.
make
cuz I was just like,
Yes.
it sounds like you're really trying to find a way to optimize the cards you're buying based on all of the factors around these different shows because you kind of got an understanding of these shows are going to happen in the same place.
Yeah.
But the one thing that's more variable is the demographics that I'm pulling in. So, I just want a way to know like, all right, if I spend 50 60 bands on cards,
Heat.
you see what I'm saying? I know that these cards are going to sell out at n, you know what I'm saying? Like,
Yes.
I'm gonna sell out 90% of my stock because it's targeted directly for those buyers at
Yes. Yes.
Yeah,
Yes.
that location at that event. Yeah.
Right. Yes.
there we
Okay. All right.
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. No, it just Yeah.
go.
No, that's that's fire. All
Yeah. It definitely It's definitely a bottom line kind of conversation.
right.
You're trying to make sure that what you pull up with you actually sell out of so that way you don't have to over buy type
Yeah.
s*.
Right.
Yeah.
Right. Yeah. No, that's fire cuz Yeah, it's all it's always different. Like LA is like I got a show in LA next week. That's going to be different than Starlate next month, which is going to be different than Atlanta next month.
Right.
So
Right. Whereas like All right. So, I'm seeing what you're saying where it's like,
yeah.
all right, some of these bigger shows. They're looking for more of those flashy type cars cuz you might get more of the noobs in the area
Yes.
or in the game that just want to see holographic shiny s*
Right.
versus one of these smaller type shows where it's like, nah,
Yes.
these is where the real collectors pull up. They looking for they'll buy energy cards off you if they from the first gen. You know what I'm saying? Like,
Yeah.
Right.
godamn.
And then seeing that seeing that age demographic,
Okay.
you know how the a you know how the 16 to 24 year olds collect and buy. You know that they're a little bit faster flippers. The young homies I know in that s*, they like,"Oh man,
Right.
they bust a pack. They got this. Here they come." But I mean, because my brother, my little brother do that s*. or it's the 24 to 30 to we're we're pretty prestigious in it but kind of like you what show is going to get you're kind of in that middle ground like I can service both of those and then you got your classic OGs that are really like you said oh that's the original water energy from like you see how it look what
you want to do and at least
Whatever. Whatever. Yeah.
you can at least you can get something so yeah studying that demographic and those ages um around the
Yeah.
Mhm.
area. I would say I would say let me see how to do this.
Let me see cuz there's there's like because you can't get like the email list.
Right.
You can't get the email list cuz if you had the email listed event it'll be ball game you know exactly who was
You be Yeah, you be in
there um I would say
there. He could type use the Apollo method on the decision makers and
okay
the vendors and s* that usually pull up to some of these things and then kind of gauge it from how those businesses are branding and marketing themselves cuz they're all targeting certain demographics too.
All
you know,
that is
it be a little bit roundabout because you can't necessarily get the direct email list of the people that are pulling up to the event, but maybe kind of going like,
Oh,
all right, boom, you all right,
right.
you're on social media, you follow some of these people that be pulling up. So, you'll hear in advance, months ahead of time, hey, this person at whoever, whoever Pikachu lover 92 is pulling up to this s*, they got a 100,000 followers.
You can kind of start scraping their social media off some fire crawl s*.
Yeah.
Start start, you know what I'm saying? Start seeing what Yeah.
Or even um Amplify.
Even Amplify still. Yeah.
Amplify.
Really start understanding
So yeah, that's a good time.
It's a Apple
Amplify.
that.
Amplify the top people s*
phone.
and check and re and reverse engineer uh those audiences for sure.
Mhm.
That's a good one.
Okay. No, that's fire.
Yeah.
I appreciate y'all cuz I was like there's got to be a way these two connect in in that specific part of
the this uh the knowledge y'all was dropping for sure. But no, that Yeah. And I when you were saying I was even thinking just going the people that follow the actual show promotions like cuz like if I live in Hickory I'm going follow all of the inside pitch shows because they they one of the biggest promoters of shows in Hickory.
Right.
So then I guess I could just scroll through that and find the demographic too physically and digitally and then skip that line
And even bro and even when you show up see now if you start doing
up.
I gota look back at your page. If you do collector content, what's gonna happen is here's what I did with Investfest. Didn't I tell you what I did with Investfest?
Yes, sir. Why you don't?
I was like, run that one.
Yes.
Run that one.
Do a do a meta ad on a on a 10 mile radius of the event. So now everybody at the event, they already and then they already know what you got. So if the event is on Friday or if the event is on Friday and Saturday, Monday to Thursday, engagement at 10 15 mile radius, certain age demographics, and you can kind of leave it broad when you do this one because you're you're you're messing with the uh with the collectibles and
stuff. So, I think on meta you might be able to even target Pokemon cards or something.
I'll look into it. Um, collectors in a certain area. Leave the age I mean you can leave the age open because you're trying to get back data and the more and more you get data. So if you go to 12 events and you got all the data on 12 events you can start to definitely you can start to definitely roll that up and AI is going to start to notice. So now you'll say okay well what do I do with a ad? And again, you're making
you're making uh not salsy content, but trader content. What's going on, y'all? Busting back busting down um five of these packs right here. Let's see what I get. Bro, that s* rips. n, it's just going to rip. Yo, I got the what's her name? And what's going to happen is the person that seen you bust the pack and get that what's her name? If you see me at If you see me at what's the name?
They want that.
If you see me at Poke Con,
Yeah.
They going to reach right out to you.
you feel me?
You got the card I want.
And they gonna reef right out and say and say,
What the
Yeah.
"Uh uh, Pokey, bro, I I see I see you in Georgia.
f*?
Just Georgia this weekend. I seen you get that. What's the name? So what you doing? You selling it. It's not salesy in your in your uh content of course, but look what I hit on and and since it's in that area, you'll make another piece of organic content. Atlanta, what's going on, man? I'm at I'm at Poke Con, man. I I got the top stuff. You know what I'm saying? I got I got some good I got some good family with me. I'm
looking for this. I'm looking for that. Just state your claim. It's just organic content. It's just you doing a yap video. Yeah, y'all. You know, the community not really tied into collectibles, Pokemon cards. Y'all are not on the lookout for the Nudo. The same s* you told me in real life.
Y'all are not really on the lookout for Nuto. So, I'm just saying like, and then you're kind of yapping.
Mhm.
thinking,"Yeah, that's the thing about your content. You don't have to sell the card and the collectibles are going to speak for themselves." f saying,"Yeah, man. Click the link in the bio." No, y'all. You know, I just feel like in the in the in the in the community, we're not often down here at something like this. And that's just a yap video of something to get engagement. Now, that'll go on engagement. Now, the awareness
one, the awareness campaign, that's why I say eat. Awareness would be,"Yo, what's going on? I just landed in Atlanta. I'm going to Poke Con this weekend. Um I'm looking for this. I'm looking I'm looking for advanced traders. I'm looking for advanced collectors, you know, to mingle with that. That's my type of party. Um I got this type of stuff. So I'm looking to mingle. I'm looking to connect. And the very demographic
you're looking for is going to connect with you.
It's an ad. you put an ad budget to it, but it's just organic content and
Mhm.
you know where they're going to be Friday and Saturday And you know there's the potential that if you see me at Pokemon, if you see me at investments, tap me on the shoulder and ask for the gift. That's organic concept.
Got it. Got it. I appreciate y'all boys for sure. Dropping gems on the head top.
It's it's healthy. Uh uh um Dr. Tonee did say um check out hopper nickspace.com. We're sending collectibles in the space and returning then auctions said assets at a,000x
So places like Copernic Space is where billionaires come to play. We're now opening up Copernic space into our communities. We have a door way finally open.
Happy.
show.
I appreciate you, Dr.
That's who we need to be.
So 10 and
Tony.
Elon ain't the only n in in in orbit.
and well Elon ain't inviting the n* to to his whole f table.
Not born.
We invited you the door open right now. So for example, you do collectibles. We sent out uh a someone's Pokemon. It's it's windy where I am, so if you guys can't hear me, please let me know.
It's low, but we can hear you
We sent out sent out a collection uh
though.
that was worth 50,000. You that went up in our cargo or or one of the items that was in our cargo on the space mission and then it returns. So now that Pokemon asset has a new IP classification.
Crazy
That $50,000 Pokemon collection that was only valued at 50,000 sold in auction for over 5 million.
That's
5 million. So my partner Harold and I were the first African-Americans, blacks, whatever they want to call us, but um invited to their space program. So we we're creating infrastructure for us to have a lean and have a way within that industry.
I
That's where your for real money is.
Keep doing what you doing,
got
but we need y'all over here with us,
Let's do it.
too.
I requested access. in the spot.
Um I I just wanted you to check it out. You can't get granted access in that way. There's a whole academy that you have to go through. You have to learn the language through the industry and then um after you pass then you will be able to um apply for your space passport. So there is a an act and an art to learning this particular industry before being granted access will chop up.
Definitely definitely uh Lindy Harris Jr. hand is up.
Yes, sir. Uh, just had a quick question. So, I'm in merchant services, but I'm trying to Can you hear me?
Yeah. Loud and clear.
Okay. I'm building uh So, I'm in merchant services, but I'm trying to build a business differently. So, like instead of building a big sales team or constantly co-roing like I want a system where I can identify the merchant who already showing a sign like they are ready to need a processor, I can verify that they fit the business that I need.
Bring them in only when there's a real opportunity.
What's the play? Did he
So,
make
I'm looking to basically bring in bring in business without having to do the cold prospecting. So, build a
it without having to do cold prospecting?
You still got to do cold prospecting.
system.
Yeah,
I understand what you're saying
you got you got to do cold.
though.
You got to do cold and you warm them up and then you heat them up.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I get what you're saying in terms
Like in class what we said to um Yeah. Go ahead.
Especially with merchant services because,
of
you know, I'm trying to target them right when they're ready to
I mean,
switch.
I can dig that. I can dig that. But when you do cold prospecting, you force them to switch cuz you're giving them the information. You're giving them a reach out and say,
Okay.
"Hey, if uh you wanted to do this, you wanted to do that, hey, where are the folks?" When you have that idea, think of it. You know, sometimes you have to do your injury lawyer ad. It it's simply a precaution. In the case you get to an accident,
Mhm.
remember spinning them at at hot dog. Come on.
Okay.
Is it you hitting,
you know what I'm saying? If it if it won't be cold outreach, it's just leave yourself up to be known. You know, cold,
Okay.
you know, that cold ass and then it'll warm people up to know you. They might not have to do engagement. date. But as long as they're aware, if you hit them with some awareness to, hey, I am here, then you'll get them cheaper. You'll get cheaper views anyway. And it'll kind of warm them up to, well, I need to keep I I need to keep this type of person, this type of business in a phone book or or or offer something to where
when you are ready to switch, we'll take care of you.
Like listen what they do to each other uh in phone. When you're ready to switch from Sprint, make sure when you when you switch from Sprint, hey, we give you a $500 off. Like damn. Like,
All
okay. Like, g like what do you got over there to where you're going to save me 500 bucks and I'm about to switch and s*.
right.
I'm been laying on Sprint two months anyway. You make people think, you force
All right. I appreciate
it.
And then you definitely got to think about the fact that even as you find these
that.
merchants that are showing these signals, I'm I'm going to get back to those signals that you're discussing in a second, but even as you're finding these merchants that are showing these signals, you're still reaching out to them as a cold product. They don't know you. They don't trust you.
Right.
They have no real reason to outside of you presenting them a solid offer.
So again, this is why I'm like, I understand what you're saying. You don't want to just be sending emails to just any old merchant. You see what I'm saying?
Right, right,
You do want to target them based on the signals that they're showing.
right,
So then that leads me to ask,
right.
what are those signals that you would be able to discern publicly that you could then leverage in your um
Mhm.
cold outreach pipeline, right? Because then that becomes something you can automate, right? because I've done something very similar in my cold outreach pipeline where instead of just reaching out to businesses that more or less match my
Right.
ICP,
you know what I'm saying?
Right.
I started using a lot of different public APIs that would give me a bunch of additional business signals. Did they just receive a round of investment?
So Okay.
Are they running ads on Facebook? Because again, the face the meta ads library is public.
Yeah.
you can run that and you can see how much they're spending on all different stuff. There's a bunch of different public things that I could then leverage to then say,"Okay, I'm not just going to spray a thousand emails at a thousand random businesses that just match my ICP.
Right.
I'm going to send these thousand emails to businesses that are showing all the signals that I would need to feel comfortable saying, hey yo, I'm going to spend whatever money I'm spending in AI usage and my time and my effort to reach out to these
Exactly.
people because they genuinely need what I want.
Exact.
But that's still cold prospecting in my mind,
Okay.
right?
Get
Yeah.
I'm just getting more particular about how I'm filtering and quality
Okay.
back.
gating who I'm doing all of this upfront work for because again it's not just oh I email them.
I have to make them a tantalizing offer. So that's still time that I'm going to have to take to build that offer, do that research. I'm damn near doing the work up front in the hopes that you'll pay me for a process that I
Right. You're from in the work.
already started type s*. You see what I'm saying?
Okay.
So,
Yeah.
I understand where you're going, but you can't avoid the cold prospecting.
What you're actually asking is how do I set up better quality filters? And that's why I'm asking, where are your signals coming from? What are
Exactly. Okay. Yeah,
they?
that's that's that's what I think I was really trying to say without having the language to say it.
But no, real talk, what are those signals? was like,"How do you know a merchant is even like ready to
So, like right now I'm working on seeing if if I can like scan through like Reddits and things like that because when people have
switch?"
pain points, they talk about it. So, if they talk about it, I need to identify where it is. So,
Yes.
then that way I can just trigger those people from those places.
Yeah.
So, I'm working on trying to basically get the intent watch ahead of time so I know exactly where to
Mhm.
go.
Yeah.
Okay. Healthy.
Then that Reddit plays one of the best players.
Healthy.
go to Reddit ads and then based on based on your site,
Exactly.
you'll get back um the r slashes that lead to exactly where your where your customer is. I like that about Reddit ads. As soon as you get there, they make the ads for you. Top five recommended based on your website.
Okay.
Soon as you put it
Yeah, cuz like I'm working on something that has like an intent watch where I can kind of get like a notify if someone is complaining about
in
something, any signal that I that way I know I can jump on right there and try to catch them before they they moved on. So, I'm working on trying to do something like
Yep.
that.
So do a fire crawl, do a amplify type thing. Read um you know ampify a fy.
You said amplify. I amplify. All
Okay.
it search it's able to search the internet uh I think Instagram Tik Tok on what's being
right.
said what are the key words so amplify and then you'll be good on answer the public answer the public that's where you going to go and put in the
Okay.
keywords that you're looking for it's going to find and it's going to find what people are asking to AI how you answer
Yeah.
And see, I have so many on additional services that once they're in, I could possibly just from my background and my knowledge, then kind of hook them into more and something different. But right now,
Yep.
I'm just trying to do the the first thing to get them in the door to then sell them all the additional things later on.
Yep. Definitely.
That's the one. That's the
You go in there with the cross sales, upselles once they're in the ecosystem of the initial offer.
one.
Right.
Definitely play it that way.
Yeah. Cuz like I do reconciliation. So like from my aspect that's something I can offer a business right there separately from watching their money and making sure that their accounts don't get closed down or shut down from chargebacks or something like that.
Man, what are we
s*.
Okay.
n were ass was at when I was about to lose some
doing?
Yeah.
Yeah. Like I have a client right now.
dough.
He used to get chargebacks. It's been four years. He's never got a chargeback. Like he he hasn't been shut down from it at all. So So I have a little bit of like, you know, some testimony. F. Need to get into the right people.
Right.
Mhm.
Finding that audience. Yeah. Scrape the place up. Amplify the place up. Get into conversations with Reddits. Answer the public. See what people are asking AI. Make some sort of uh lead magnet. Make a quick ebook out of the top uh answers that you can give on answer the public. And in that way,
Yeah,
you'll be able to you'll be able to speak the language and speak to the direct pain points of whoever you're looking
perfect.
for.
Perfect. This is exactly what I've This is like where my mind's been going, but I haven't had the right audience or the right people to just put it out there and just get an answer.
Yeah, I got you.
Got
So when I go right here just a real quick something like when you go to answer the public um
you.
one it'll tell you. So what I like I didn't show Google ads but the thing about Google ads is more defensive advertising. You dig what I'm saying? A meta ad is a that's why I say a meta ad going to go get you paid because it's going to go tell your customer hey I'm spinning. I'm over here and I'm doing the best they are. Hey I know what you're up to. I done followed you by your de your demographics your behaviors and interest.
Check it out. A Google ad. Now, you see right here says cost per click 1693. That's because when somebody see my top word up here is chief tech officer. So, you'll put your keywords. Look for your keywords on Google. Ask Gemini what are the top keywords in your field, right? Then you'll bring each of them to answer the public. You'll see the search volume is 4.4K.
So you see that people are asking Google, asking Gemini, asking chat GPT certain questions about the role. You see chief tech officer salary, chief tech officer, you know, for in the search engines. Uh recommended cloud providers for enterprise data solutions. Now I'm going to go down here and look it says AI prompts. What if people been asking chat GBT and Gemini in AI? So now that in AI we see exactly the questions being
asked, we answer them whether it's in an advertisement. What are the key responsibilities of a chief tech officer in a startup?
Yeah.
Hey peace, what's going on? So if you're wondering what are the key responsibilities to a chief um tech officer inside of a startup, we'll go in there and we'll always look at the morning news in technology, AI, software, hardware to see where our best fit is going to be. We're going to study APIs, MCPs, and everything going around in a world of AI to keep our start up on the bleeding edge of technology, being able to
advance, save more time, save more money because and you say,"Where are people talking at?" Yes,
Reddit is good. Reddit. Run the Reddit play plus the plus the answer the public and just answer these because they've they've been getting
Mhm.
asked in AI. So when you answer something that has already been asked to AI, it gives you a better probability of being cited by AI. In a new age of SEO, it's AI citability that wins. So when you're answering questions that have been directly answered uh sorry when you are answering questions that are being directly asked to AI AI put you up as a cited source. So what you're going to do when you answer these yes is a lead
magnet um a pamphlet a booklet of some sort to where it just holds these answers. it. You could call it the top 10 answers. Well, the top 10 questions um people becoming a CTO ask. Answer them all. Use some actual intelligence and artificial intelligence. Answer them. Put them in put them in a small booklet and that's a lead magnet to get into your ecosystem just to get on your new just to get on your newsletter.
And it was always just free. You just knew where to get the information. You knew how to hop into the conversation. Okay. What are the key responsibilities of a chief tech officer? What software tools are most commonly used by chief? Again, you'll answer them in a lead, man. And then you're going to answer them in the form of a blog on your site. Also, what's a what's a bigger play?
I say I actually have a blog.
Boom.
I have a blog from another business that I started that I eventually wanted to connect together so that they can connect and feed each
Definitely. All right. So, I'll give you those, too. You can run the Reddit play. Just go to Reddit ads. You don't have to pay for any ads. The moment you put your website in. So, go ahead and put the blogs on the site, you know, hit them. Hit hit 10 blogs per question, per answer. Put out a lead magnet. And then, uh, find a way to tag your company.
Put your company in there. Well, your company answer such and such and your company's known. Give yourself a little PR. And then what's going to happen next is you're going to take your answers from answer to public and let's just go let's go to let's go to Jerry. So now when you have your answers and each piece in each blog you're just going to bring them over here and create um each blog will be a different source. And
then what's next is so you you don't have to be tied to nothing like this y'all. This is why I tell y'all about satellite pages to where your face doesn't really show up, but your information does cuz watch this. Now, you're going to go and take all your information. Now, these are all your answers right here from Answer the Public. You've answered them in a blog. Those are your blogs. You're going to go over here to video
overview. You're going to go to short byte-size overview to help you quickly grasp core ideas from your sources. Boom. Boom. And then that happens.
So, What you do next with that kick down with that with that video? You just go make a faceless You just go make a faceless YouTube, a faceless Tik Tok, a faceless Instagram, and you just put out you put out these answers to the questions in a short. Now, your face not even on any content, but your business and your information is. And what's going to happen is it's going to explain it's going to answer in the form of
a video and especially on YouTube, especially on Instagram. See, it takes all of them. Well, especially, you know, I'm saying if it's long enough on YouTube. So, if you did a cinematic or an explainer, you did cinematic or explainer, it'll be longer than 3 minutes and turn into a video. And in the description of the video is just the text from the blog. Now, the video is giving out audio that's answering the top questions
being asked in the AI. Below is the direct blog and the link to your site to read the blog. You're hitting at three different points of contact on one question and one answer to boost you up into AI assignability.
And you're in the mix. You're in the conversation. So, you're you you tend to become the expert in that lane because again, even if they don't see your face and you're doing a faceless channel, the link is the link that goes to your site. They still haven't seen a face. We didn't need a We didn't need a We didn't kind of didn't need a face to change chicken to go get some chicken. Like, we kind of didn't need a face at
Chase Bank to go do some banking. We kind of didn't need a face for Rotorooer. We just knew some plumber was going to come through and get the work done. with those blogs, with those micro videos and everything leading back to your uh back to the blog and back to your site, you become you become cited across all sites. The the Reddit r/con conversation, you enter that conversation, you put your and then you just put the
link to your videos, right? And then nobody knows. You're not in there harassing the r slash. You're not harassing the conversation.
is that, hey, y'all are asking this very thing in this conversation. Hey, I seen this video. That's the answer. That makes sense. Did that make sense?
Yeah. No,
I don't know if he fell off on him.
no, no. Yeah. This is exactly what I've been This is This is what I've been looking for.
All right, there it is.
Th this is this is the missing link because I feel like I've had all the pieces, but it's just putting them together and using the actual language models the correct way to Get the desired outcome.
There it is. Those plays right there to get in the conversation and dominate the conversation. Is that like that for all of y'all? Answer the public Reddit with your with your URL, right? And do the blogs first, bro. Do it everybody. This this is the kind everybody think when you want to when you want to capitalize on the information, put 10 blogs up answering those first 10 questions from Answer the Public so they're
up, you know, a top nine top 10 blogs already on the site so that when Reddit reads the site, it knows the exact conversation to put you in because there's so many blogs and so much information on that one thing, two things that is your business, that is your offer.
So now it gives you the top conversations that they should be a part of. And then don't throw the ad in there. If you want to throw the ad, throw the ad, but scrap the ad and just join the r/ conversation. You'll get in there, you'll see the right questions. You know what you're going to do, man. I found this video on YouTube. Look, I'm Sebastian, man. They got this new They got this new Mitchi s* out, man. You're not
harassing the conversation and you're fitting your answer and your blog in your notebook LM videos that answer it and having a text for triple AI signability and putting it into the right conversation.
This is exactly exactly what I was missing.
That's how we do it,
Like I appreciate y'all for
man. That's where it's at.
real.
It's healthy. run that up though. I don't want to catch you on the internet and you didn't do it. That's what it really saying. Uh Daniel, your hand still up.
Like what you got, bro? I kind get to a couple other people. I just want to make sure.
Yeah. Question.
Yeah.
When they do the tors, is it like a AI generated video? Put no to them.
On Yep. It's good ass videos,
Yeah.
too, bro. I'll show you.
Okay.
I I'll bring one up in a minute.
Let me hear uh let me hear from um Jessica Lewis, please.
Good evening everyone.
Good evening. Good evening. Good
This is in my head is just so
health.
I'm very new to the AI space.
All
Um right now I'm just using it in a very basic way just asking it questions.
right.
I just use claw to reorganize my calendar, things like that. I'm in construction. I also have a tax business that I found a way to merge the two companies
Okay.
together. Long story short, I'm curious to hear with those two particular markets, um, some of the tools.
I I love the marketing piece that that just blew my whole head up.
Mhm.
Um, I'm appreciating how y'all showing us how to use Notebook LM. I can repurpose old content by using some of the these different tools that's built into that.
Yeah.
Are there any other tools for my industry specifically? I would say financial services, real estate, construction that would be really good tools to use to kind of maximize and connect to a marketing campaign.
So you want to you want to blend the two.
Okay.
So are you going to do are you going to help construction companies structure their taxes?
Well, no. So, let me explain how the two fit together. So, I've been in the industry a really long time,
Cool.
and my customer's greatest challenge was getting loans from the banks,
Hold on. Hold
whether it's residential or commercial. So,
on.
I also have been in taxes longer than I've been in my construction industry. 10 years for construction, 18 years for taxes.
A lot of the reason why people don't get approved is because of collateral credit or how much income they have. The way that I do taxes, it shows their income being much higher than they normally would if they were taking the route of trying
Right.
to do deductions and charitable donations and all of that. So when I do their taxes is actually shown their income to be much higher. So they can now get approved for mortgages, any kind of loan, anything they could want. So in turn, as they get approved for these loans, they would then come back to us and um pretty much they're self-paying to get their construction projects done. Uh long story short, I merge the two services
together where probably the first I would say the first thing I do for them is to help them do the tax piece so that we can then do the design consultations. We can create their you know their vision board, their mood board for their project. then they can take that along with our contract, our um line item budget, all that stuff to the lender along with the taxes of course the tax filings and now they qualify for more
than they probably needed to do their project.
So I was able to combine the two together in that way. And right now, as I said, I'm just using it AI in a very basic way. Just trying to be productive, managing appointments, you know, doing design consultations, renderings, things like that. But I would like to see if there maybe an elevated way that I could use it to maybe streamline um those process, be able to market to a new customer that we offer all of that in-house.
Right.
And then I would say finally being able to from a project management perspective create uh some kind of automated system where as they're going through this workflow from taxes to the construction and all the things that happen in between um from their sign up time a way for them to go through that seamlessly with I would say minimal human contact if possible. levels. So we have to do the oneto ones you know for design
and taxes but all the other in between things and also being able to market to them will be super helpful for
I ain't going to be able to market to them.
us.
So the infrastructure of how it works, you know all the SOPs, you know how to get them from A to Z.
Yes.
what we have to do is digitize and what we said codify the process. So if we look at if we look at um what we spoke about the skills connectors and
plugins we can look at different skills or even when you do the process. So every time you have a success you'll go ahead and document that with Claude. When you document that with Claude,
Okay.
look, we took this company here. They were going through this. We were able to get this done, this done, this done, and that done. We're able to retain, we're able to uh do it in this timeline.
Oh
Give a nice explanation of how the mundane task,
god.
how the human touch went first because that's a lot of things about AI agents and automations. Again, it's actual intelligence first.
So, how did you actually do it? And then how did you actually do it nine more times?
Mhm.
So by the 10th time you run through it with Claude, it's time. If this business model was a plugin, what would it need? And then then let's look in here and browse real quick. Let's look in here and browse. See, it might not have a construction company plugin because hey,
Yeah.
maybe Anthropic has not done what you do. So it wouldn't be there.
Okay.
So you're looking look investment banking. Investment banking productivity tools. Is that something that might can fit the claw Microsoft 365? Could that fit? Regulatory legal. Could that fit? Look at here goes AI governance legal. Could that fit? If you're not finding any fits again in your process, I'd go back to Claude and I'd explain out exactly what you explain to me. This why I tell y'all sometimes, go ahead and
put it on voice mode.
I'm on I'm recording right now as we speak so I didn't have to repeat it
Explain, right? And then Yep. And then you're in there in voice mode saying,"Hey, Claude, well, I've done this. We found this out. We've done this. We've done that." Boom. Boom. Boom. we see here. Now, if my business model were to be a plugin with connectors and skills, show me what that would look like. Let Claude break it down based off its own plugins, connectors, connectors you might have to make if you want to go
high level, going whatever is in your business. Okay?
Mhm.
Those connectors, those plugins, those skills. Now, if this were to uh multiple a plugin chain how we explained earlier. Let it break it down by each plugin that actually might be. Now we going to go back in there and I didn't see any skills or plugins. Let me see me browse plugins again. Act uh nothing about
Maybe financial
construction. know, hey, Paul, when it comes to building out plugins, connectors, and skills, how would I do this part, this part, this part? What part would be a skill?
What what would I need to connect with? And how would we draw out the plugin? You just keep asking that in a loop until it breaks it down. And you're going to look back at Claude and say,"Okay, this is it. Can we make those skills?" And then what what um plugin and how can I
Mhm.
customize? Because again, look right here. We're at plugins. Look at we go add marketplace. Add from repository. Sync a plugin marketplace from GitHub repository or get because that's why we said to codify the process.
Let's check it out. When you lay that out and you turn the plug in into connectors and skills, see now it does have to become a code. It becomes a system. And I think hit and now caught this in something called get money get built is because the GitHub repository could actually be the entire business because that's
Right.
what structures the plug-in chains based off your successes and failures that you walk claw through like claw no that didn't happen.
We had to look at this paperwork this documentation. They had did this two three years ago. So, we had to contact this person and do that. So, now the agent understands the process, turn into a SOP, turns into a cycle,
Okay.
turns it into code, and then now you'll customize an absolute plugin by going to the plugins, pressing the plus, and it's like anthropic. Y'all didn't have what I needed.
Mhm.
I turned into a GitHub repository. Or even just get it done by Claude. Get it done by claw. So when you're in that skill, when you're having that ability, right, you'll come in here again to connectors to connectors and look at that GitHub integration. So you know what that means?
When I'm done on Claude, I'm going to push it to GitHub as a company company infrastructure. You see, Claude built up the plugin.
Uhhuh.
Hey, turn this into code and push that company over into GitHub. That make sense? Now it lives in GitHub.
Yes.
It's a company.
You might launch it on something else, make it a app. Or you can come back to the plugins, press add, add marketplace. add from repository and now pull your business, your codified business back out and now your claw can run that plugin. Anytime you get a client, anytime you're on a call, all the automated processes in which you've been through in real life 10 times becomes a skill and a plugin to where you just put in
their business. You just listen to them on a call, explain their situation, turn over the transcripts back to Claude and say,"Activate the activate the construction tax skill that we use for our business uh plugin." Sorry. And it'll take them through every task that doesn't need a human and happen on our
Nice.
pilot.
I had another question in reference to is it is it y'all call it the MPC? So that's like when you connect.
uh MCP model concept protocol.
Correct.
So you got the model you know then the model you say large language model it has to think for everybody at the same
So,
time. It's going to take other questions and answers and it might teach you the same question and answers based on
okay.
what that person said. The model what does it do? How does it go? The concept. What's the concept? What are what are we doing it for?
Got it.
Why would we intake a client? Why would we market an advertise? Does it go back to a funnel? Does it go to a landing page? Is this for a webinar? What's the concept? Okay, great. And what's that cycle?
Mhm.
We kind of talked we kind of talked about it like a plugin is kind of a kind of MVP because what's the concept? Why are we doing this? When are we doing this? What needs to be automated? What needs to be uh done by a human? You know, how much does it cost? What are these connects? That's the concept. And then the protocol in which it happens is pretty much the the loops, the code uh and infrastructure SOPs.
Yep. That you can just put in and plug and play from your application or your software into
Mhm.
another. So I'll have a new new ainty uh MCP where I have an automated marketing agency. Everything that I pretty much said today is in the brains of new ainty. So, a new Minty MCP over in your software. Now, it'll scrape like we do. It'll it'll do um uh competitor research like we do. It'll it'll it'll word copyright like we do. It'll do ads how we do. But it's in your software. It's on your model. Your model's thinking
like new emitting. our our concepts, our reasons, our triggers and our
I like that. And in that same thought process of how you just described,
protocol.
if we created something like that, which was y'all original question to me, do I want to help other construction companies? Once I create this right here, then that's an opportunity for me to offer this as a service to any real estate or construction related
Yep.
industries.
Yeah. You always want to do that, y'all. And that's for everybody. Once you learn these skills and your AI learned those skills with you, you have a skill to sell. Now, automated marketing,
Nice.
I have a skill to sell there, right? I'll teach you it. I'll do it for a company. But if you're a marketing agency and you want to figure out how to use fire crawl plus amplify plus new a mentee connected to answer the public for the best answers, well, you can license the software. Or I can show you this, too. So I can go to other marketing agencies and say,"Well, in my agency, we ran up six figures in a month because
we did this, this, and this. We fed this back. We have this tool, and hey, you can you can use it, too, in your marketing agency, and you should be see be able to see a bump in in advertisements because again, we're watching them. We have we have meta ads watchers uh watcher agents in here and then do that process for them.
That's exactly how it goes. Turn your skill into a dollar
I have one last question. If I wanted to create this entire let's say infrastructure for the business
bill.
to convert it into a app where some of the processes could be because right now I do a lot of things onetoone and I'm trying to minimize my oneto ones.
Right.
Is there a way or does it make sense just based off of what we just talked about here to convert it into a app where they can kind of do some of these things on their
Yep. Yep. For sure.
own?
That's too easy. The same way we just sent it all that all that to get a plug in to a repository in GitHub, right?
Mhm.
Bring that same bring that same GitHub repo down to Lovable and then turn it into a um a fully autonomous app. It's that easy. Put the prompt to it. Put the prompt to the same GitHub. It's either going to become a plugin or it's become an app on lovable
Love it. Thank you.
Andy.
May I please please speak to that sp
Uh I mean we do got Naen but yeah. Go Tony. Go ahead.
okay I have a C funding business so I have the indepth experience with what she is speaking about and
Okay.
that's the only reason why I asked to speak so what makes what uh the the process Of course,
the way that you explained is doable. Where that conflict lies is that any construction any construction project, no matter how how minute or even if you're going from the ground up, we fund anywhere from 5 million to 1 billion projects. You need to fund either the acquisitions, the bridge, the remodel, uh the horizontal or the vertical.
All
And in doing so,
right.
every county is different. The permits are going to be different as far as the cost. So, what I do in order to package up my clients to prepare them for funding if they don't know how to package themselves up, which they usually don't.
Uh, of course, the business plan is needed. Financials are needed. Um, and your f your financials have to coincide with all of your uh permits. So, what I do is I build a operations research agent first.
There I
And that operations research agent is going to go and search that specific
go.
county in order to pull all of those permits, how long it takes to get those permits, where you got to apply for those permits, all of the details based on that specific project. So why this can't be uh it can be systemized but it cannot be customized for one lane is because all these different projects vary so drastically. So you start with your operations agent and then you're going to have your uh financials agent.
your financials agent is going to be able to pull data from your operational your operations agent because your financials got to a line whenever you're looking to get funding um for the scope of the project. It has to make sense. Once people send me their projects, I'm going to know right off the top if the if the math ain't math, y'all's numbers is f* up somewhere.
Excuse my language. numbers got to make sense across the board for projects like this based on the type of
Yeah.
project. And then you also have to have your um your
Right.
um your project manager that is trained in in the ways of construction overall which your uh project manager. Your project manager agent is going to be able to review the financials, re review the operations, and be able to cultivate your project from there. So again, because every project is different, you know, it's it's hard to set set rules and set customizations for said projects because they all vary stateto state,
county to county, law for law, um, number for number. And then I top all of that off, especially with the financials and the project management um agent to with all of the underwriting criteria. So, I make sure that the project meets my lenders underwriting criteria. off the back in order to ensure funding for my projects. So, if that helps you have a better idea of how to cultivate your system, um I just wanted to share
that.
You're the best. Thank you, Dr.
You're very welcome. I think uh it's been stepped away for a minute but please ask any questions. I want to ensure that you understand the process um and understand the intricacies whenever you're creating your system.
I had a question in reference to what you just mentioned which was a follow-up question. I'll wait for my time my turn because I know there's some people in front of me but I do have a question in reference to what he just said and what you said and how to connect things that are not there's no connector for it basically.
Hey, Jessica. I'm Christina. Um,
Yes.
I have a question for you if you don't mind. Um, are you a tax preparer or are you operating as a a tax service bureau?
Neither. Um I actually used to be both. And the brother earlier in the call he mentioned uh people learn certain things.
Okay.
So once I learned that I was an Asian of the government, I actually removed myself from their system.
So I actually had a P10, I was a tax service bureau, erra, all that good stuff. Now I actually educate people directly so that you don't need any of those agents to help you
Mhm.
with your filings. So, I actually have a one-to-one mentoring class where I teach you exactly how to do your own filings, how to troubleshoot if you have issues with the IRS, um how to correct any past filings so that your filings are proper,
so that you're showing proper income because that's a whole another thing. Most people,
I'm out.
they're trying to get charitable donations and deductions and all kind of stuff. And the more you put on there,
Mhm.
the less your income is. So when you go to apply for these loans, you look like you're a liability to lenders. So I teach you how to also some of the things with Dr.
Got it.
Tony said,"Underst understanding underwriting so that you look your best." All legit.
All the Exactly.
Mhm.
Excuse me. present yourself and how you're supposed to present yourself versus trying to lower your tax liability. taxes aren't even real. That's a different conversation. But um I just I I'm in the space now where I'm educating people on
Right.
how to properly file so that they are getting more money back because you're entitled to
Okay.
it. And then of course the other side is making sure your income is showing so you can get whatever you want as well because those are birthright entitlements as well.
Right.
So
So, the reason why I asked is because I'm actually transitioning from being a service bureau. So, if you wouldn't mind messaging me how to join that class with you, um, I would love to learn a little bit more about what you were just talking
Indeed.
about.
I'll send I'll put my information here in the chat. Thank you all.
Okay.
For sure. For sure. Can I get uh Nadine, please? We are coming up on that time, y'all. I'm not I'm not about to blitz y'all, but me and him been working for uh 10 plus hours. Look out for your brothers. Nadine, what's over with it? Damn. What's up, D? I'm run off on your ass cuz I'm almost 40. Like, get me off this camera. Yeah, she raise her hand on accident. Um, if there are any uh last questions for these last about
10 minutes, y'all, let me let me let me do 10 more minutes. Uh, anything extra.
I do I do have one more
We'll see y'all
question.
tomorrow.
Sure. It's in reference to what we just talked about and also what Dr. um Tonee had added. So my question is around what if we're trying to create something that's unique like how you saw there's no construction there's no tax plugins or connectors what if we needed to connect to something that does not like for instance I'll give this specific example Dr. Tony talked about how the cost of construction even costs from
um costs different from city to city, state to state, whatever.
Long story short, there are websites that actually help you with the most up-to-date pricing for these that particular industry. I was curious to understand when they don't have a connector or plugin or something like that, is there a way that we can train our AI to extract data from these sources to then bring it back into the fold so that it can help us become more accurate in our outputs.
I would answer that the same way I kind I kind of did.
It's
I mean, Dr. Tonee sees it different cuz I think when I break it down by the context, by the system, how it is, I think I I do invent um when I've done an app before to where something a certain math sequence didn't really exist One more. Right. There are certain softwares that that go around and maybe it it the software doesn't really again connect taxes with with construction and know what Dr. Tonee knows. But since Dr.
Tonee knows the context of it, I think she even knows if she codified that s*, that would be a sport of invention.
That would be something new, something fresh in AI. I don't tend to say like if you haven't done a certain amount in AI, I wouldn't invent any math, any science, any code in it. But hey, if you stumble across something new to where you are the creator of that plugin, if you are the creator of that loop based on what Dr. Tonee says, of course it's going to take human elbow grease. But in the age of AI and code and how it's
moving, I'm like,"Bro, we gonna invent anything.
Yeah, I
It might not be in connectors, plugins, and skills,
agree.
but again, when making up apps, when we're doing apps and you're really engineering, like that's that's AI engineering 101 is that whatever process doesn't exist, I'm going to invent it based off math, based off code, based off timing, and then based off of actual intelligence. So the same way she knows what type of land, what type of deal, what type of strategy, the city, the city ordinance, the state. Okay. Well, she
even started the she even started the answer with a particular agent and the agent knows what she knows.
You dig what I'm saying? And it's like, okay, well, um, I know this and I know that,
Exactly.
and hey, agent, you need to look for this the same way we did with with my version of marketing. Okay. Well, the 3%, the 10%, the 15%, the 25 watchers, the 50 watchers, the 75 watchers, the 95 watchers. Nobody on Anthropic knew that because not it's not what they do. that GPT wouldn't have told you to do it like that because it's a large language model. It didn't think of this micro strategy in a pretty decent niche which
is AI automated marketing. So what about AI AI automated marketing? Well, look for this, look for that. Boop boop boop. Fry for this. And then here, let me see what this is about it. Daniel said,"Question, no APIs available. All sites are closed and locked up. Is this the only route? Is the only route to manual data?" Uh, hold on, bro. But with the with the advent of a of a new code and which way it flows, I'm saying that's
again that's engineering and development.
And I'm pretty sure it it's been many times me or hit or or a engineer figured out something that didn't exist inside of something. or how do you become a competitor to something that doesn't exist? You you you kind of give yourself competition. You know what I mean? I kind of again like I said, one engineer, one hacker. How do we build this up? Where does it meet in the middle? How does it work? How does it break? Who
is it for? Who's it not for? So, I mean, that's how I look at engineering. It is it it's it's engineering is kind of inventing but it's inside of a code and a machine. So sometimes they don't give you the phrase of oh this is an invention but if I process human emotion times human um environment times willingness to travel times budget equals experience. What kind of app am I making? and I invented and I engineered and
reverse engineered those loops, MCPs, reasons, plugins, turned it all into code and put it into the app. You can't tell me you can't tell me I didn't invent something new.
I think it would take a conversation with somebody like that's why I said go get real mentorship so you can see how you can invent. I don't again I don't recommend inventing but hey nobody has a plugin nobody has a course nobody has an app that will plug me in based on Dr. I got I sat with Dr. Tonee for hour. I got the full game, the full landscape about the city, about the house, about the land, about the general contractors,
the timing, the weather, the, you know, what type of acreage is on, retail verse agricultural, and how we can and then we can run the math and code. That probably don't buy code because you'll never sit back and build an app that's going to do that. You need to really sit down and engineer. So again, that's how I see engineering, y'all. Okay,
Yes.
that's my that's my bright idea about things that don't
Um,
Thank
exist.
I was having some technical issues and I know the time is up so I'll just, you know, keep my question until tomorrow.
No, don't worry about it. Let's get
Okay,
it.
fine. So, I was saying that I just moved back to Jamaica from Germany after having lived there for a while and
Uh oh.
I was made redundant through AI. So, I decided to learn AI to understand, you know, what's happening. And so moving back to the Caribbean,
Right.
my focus now is to start a business that because there's so many solopreneurs and small businesses here in Jamaica, right? That makes up at least 80% of the econom of the business economy here outside of tourism.
All right.
So I was thinking that instead of just leading with a large complex approach that I would solve like immediate pain points, you know, like for example creating in um a follow-up system, a pipeline, something that you know um automates um repetitive operational processes. Now, I'm not starting from scratch because I'm from Jamaica, but I don't really know that many people here right now. So, I was wondering,
Okay.
you know, would leading with these focus pain points um driven products to establish trust and create the entry point into businesses, is that the right approach or should I consider marketing differently?
No, go ahead and take over your local your local market. And here's why. Here's why I say why. Uh, coming from sports, coming from fighting, all that blah blah blah. What I'm saying is you have to win city before you win state before you win national, before you win worlds. Go in there and win local. Now, if you can go to your local barber, your local food shop, and then just offer autonomy. Hey, I'm a AI um automation
strategist. Hey, I can see how this restaurant I can see how your restaurant's working. Would you like an AI to answer the phone with the knowledge of your menu, of your opening closing hours, of what you use inside of each dish? If I I can show you how I can teach AI your entire menu, your entire, you know, your story connected to advertisements around here, you know, in a in a in a 10 mile radius. That'll get you more
foot traffic on autopilot, more people to call. Um, the AI, you can still be cooking, you can still be doing this.
Your restaurant homies. Hey, down here at the barber shop. Hey, I'm an AI automation specialist uh in a barber shop. What we've been doing lately for um barbers and hair and hair salons is putting a AI um agent in front that answers the phone that does text. It it tells the it tells the prospect what type of haircuts you do or what type of braids you do or locks that you do and it lines them up and then it puts them on
your calendar with a small deposit. It pings your phone so you can just stay cutting hair and the next person will walk in on autopilot. would you like to sit down with me and do like a 20-minute demo so I can show you how it works and then get 10 businesses in your own local area now they all know you because everybody is on Naen's AI strategies and then what you're doing as you're getting paid you're making yourself
seen because again on the meta ads when you go to targeting the spot do a 20 mile radius and then you just deliver ads and deliver information.
Hey, if you're down here in Kingston, uh, and you've been looking to automate the business and doop, just give out the information, say what can be done, what can't be done, who's it for, give us a call, book a demo, and then see what you can do is when you guys are taking over local market and winning and winning. city is it show up in person. See, I had to sell y'all all across the world. I sold in Canada on this. I
sold in the UK on this. I sold in Thailand with this. If I sold all this to Atlanta and say,"Hey, Atlanta business owners, if you're looking to implement AI, instead of a 20 minute call on a Zoom or a Google Meet, hey y'all, what I've been doing out here in Atlanta is pulling up on people personally and working over your shoulder in your computer, having you um apply AI to your local business in your local market. The
same way I found you, I'll find you your local customer. Give me a call. 510747 woop whoop. I'll be glad to get on a call and I'll pull up on you and work with you
Wow.
directly.
I was thinking of a similar strategy just like that to go to like local businesses here, but like your twist on it just solidified really the idea that I had.
I'm telling you. I'm telling you. Because now you're making them, again, like I said, you're making them see you as the cities.
Perfect.
Because that's what happens in small cities and small town. That's why I like to win city because if everybody in a 20 mile radius, y'all see me at the grocery store, y'all know me as the AI automator. Nadine is the AI automator around here. Just like such and such is the barber. Just like such and such do the braids.
Mhm.
Just like such and such got that good restaurant with with with the with that. Just like what's the name do the best mobile detailing and then all those business owners in the circle all 10 all 20 of them in a 20 mile radius all know each other and know where everybody's connected and we know Nadine need to come do the maths we know we know we know Andy been doing this stuff with these AI agents win city right there 20
mile radius by time you have you're in that 20 in that 20 entrepreneur circle you put agents in everybody business everybody love you in a local area.
People in a local area, they don't have nothing. They go to those restaurants. They go to those barber shops and maybe they do own a online business. Man, you've been going crazy at the barber shop lately. Look, I'm the customer of your client, man. I've been seeing your ads go crazy. Yeah, you know, he ain't doing that s*. What's the name, too? s*. I've been trying to get online and do something. You just went from winning
city to winning state.
All right. You make it sound so easy, though. Like I said, that's exactly what I was contemplating, but I was just wondering if I if I was just going to go too small,
Oh s*.
but I guess that's just the best way to start.
Praise y'all.
Thank you so
Praise y'all. That is what's up. All right, y'all. Let's go ahead and rest and let's breathe and get ready for tomorrow when we put everything on autopilot and we take off because again I was going to pitch y'all today but me And I could have had been on the clock crazy, still delivering until from 11 to 9. Let me get the damn rest in, hit my meditation, affirmations, let me get in this goddamn tub, smoke some weed, uh,
and I will see y'all 10:45.
I'll open up the room, the emails go out. And remember y'all, um, super grateful. But not until Tuesday afternoon will these replays, and these are the long ass replays. The first one is eight hours. This one is two hours. Cool. Um, let's all prepare for tomorrow, y'all. It's going to be good stuff. So, get some rest, get your mind right. Um, and we on to the next episode. Yeah. Again, extremely grateful. I'm glad you
were able to get value out of this. Much appreciation to the team, to the squad, to the good brethren. Hitsuyo all uh and everybody that provided value inside the chat to one another. That's how you network. Uh, much appreciation. I know y'all glad Dr. Tonee came to VIP. You see, you see how Dr. Tonee didn't speak like that at the in the thing, but we needed to hear real business infrastructure. Okay, that's the thing
about being VIP. Real business infrastructure. We teach you the code. We teach you the mechanics. We saying the AI automate this agent that don't go to jail. All right. Peace to the family. Peace to you and yours once again in the VIP of the AI Autopilot Summit. What a magnificent time. Uh what a magnificent day. You guys stay healthy, stay resilient, get some rest. It's been a long Saturday full of information. Go ahead,
get some rest. Peace to you and yours. Has been your brothers from the inside of AI Spencu. Dr. Tony. Peace.
Peace.